for 28 years mark has been fishing
jersey's waters
he says the escalating row over who can
fish wear isn't good for fishermen
french or british
to me now personally it's gone too
political i think that's the problem now
i don't think the fishermen are getting
a saying into any of this
it's all the um
the governments are fighting each other
while officials fight fishermen are
trying their best to earn a living
but the fear is that tensions could boil
over again
this was the situation in jersey back in
may when french fishing vessels
protested at the island's main harbour
france doesn't believe the channel
islands or the uk government have issued
enough fishing licenses
and is threatening restrictions from
next tuesday such as extra checks and
preventing british boats from landing
their catch in france
the measures being threatened do not
appear to be compatible with the trade
and cooperation agreement or wider
international law
and if carried through will be met with
an appropriate and calibrated response
the uk has now summoned the french
ambassador over france's plans to
retaliate
they had even been talk of electricity
being dramatically cut to the channel
islands which is heavily reliant on its
power from france that threat was scaled
back on thursday with france saying that
it could increase tariffs instead
the government here in jersey says it is
extremely disappointed by the french
government's threats and insist it is
giving licenses to those entitled our
door remains open if log books are
provided that show those vessels are
fished in our waters they will be
entitled to a license under the tragedy
we've acted with goodwill we've provided
an amnesty period we've moved some
vessels into
being provided with temporary licenses
which is giving them time to provide
their log books
that amnesty ends on sunday and as of
now there are 55 french vessels on the
red list here in jersey
meaning they'll have no right to fish
these waters from next week
no one knows whether they'll leave
quietly
dan whitehead sky news instant helia
jersey